auf einmal schauen Sie uns an 2000 Jahre
alte Gesichter die erstmals in der
modernen Zeit aufgetaucht sind aus den
Fluten für den Archäologen Carlos da
Silva der wohl einzig positive Aspekt
der jahrhundertdürre am
Amazonas diese Bilder zeigen die Kultur
der frühen
amazonasvölker die Erde das Wasser und
der Wald waren die Grundlage für ihr
Überleben daran Bute viel geändert hat
wird in diesen Tagen schmerzhaft
deutlich das wasserreichste Flussgebiet
der Erde erlebt die schlimmste Dürre
seit Beginn der Aufzeichnungen noch nie
war der Unterschied zwischen Regen und
Trockenzeit so
dramatisch dort wo sie sonst Wasser im
Überfluss haben schleppen sie jetzt
Kanister wir sind zwei Stunden von
Manaos der Hauptstadt des Amazonas
entfernt die Stadtverwaltung schickt
Hilfe per Boot doch bis zum Ziel dem
Dorf jatuarana können sie nicht mehr
fahren Ortsvorsteher Narciso Ferreira
hat mit seinen 70 Jahren eine solche
Trockenzeit noch nie erlebt jetzt teilt
er ein wer welche Kanister bekommt hier
Domingos das hier ist für
dich dann machen sie sich auf den Weg
bei 40° Hitze über Hügel die sonst nur
leicht aus dem Wasser ragen von der
Seenplatte dahinter sind nur ein paar
Rinnsale übrig geblieben 40 l Wasser für
die Familie
wir begleiten Narciso und Domingos
selbst mit den kleinen flachen boten die
H alle benutzen wird es immer
schwieriger voranzukommen für eine
Strecke von sonst wenigen Minuten
brauchen wir jetzt eine halbe Stunde
immer wieder bleiben wir
stecken das geht so nicht mit dem Motor
lass uns ein Stück
zurücksetzen auch ich muss helfen das
Boot irgendwie über die Bänke Schlamm
und Sand
hinegüen der schlam ist
grausam es hilft alles nichts das Boot
ist zu schwer beladen wir müssen
aussteigen und zu Fuß weiter Domingos
fährt alleine vor bringt die schweren
Kanister zum
Haus der Fluss ist hier unsere Straße
der Teppich der uns verbindet hier in
unserer Region ist der Fluss alles ohne
den Fluss sind wir
nichts der Fluss reicht normalerweise
selbst in der Trockenzeit bis an die
Treppe jetzt ist er weit weg und voller
Schlamm zum Trinken brauchen sie das
Wasser aus den Kanistern doch schon bei
der nächsten Wasserlieferung kann es
sein dass sie selbst mit den kleinen
boten hier nicht mehr
rauskommen wir haben hier heute eine
Hitze die es früher nicht gab es ist
kaum auszuhalten nur im Schatten und mit
viel kaltem Wasser das macht uns
Sorgen das beobachtet auch Klimaforscher
Eron Beha unter anderem wenn er in seine
Glaskugel schaut die die Intensität der
Sonne misst es ist etwas aus dem
Gleichgewicht geraten am
Amazonas niedrig und hochwasserphasen
sind im Amazonasgebiet normal das ist
nicht das Problem was uns Klimaforschern
Sorgen macht ist dass diese Phänomene
immer häufiger und extremer
werden und das hat Folgen für die ganze
Welt sagt er denn die Fähigkeit des
Regenwaldes gleichmäßig Unmengen an
Wasser zu speichern und zu verdunsten
wir sich
auf das globale Klima
aus wir sprechen von fliegenden Flüssen
also Wassermassen die über dem Wald
verdunsten nach Norden und Süden ziehen
und so das Weltklima im Gleichgewicht
halten denn der Wasserdampf puffert die
intensive Strahlung und die Abholzung
des Waldes sorgt dafür dass weniger
Wasser
verdampft die Trockenzeit beginnt früher
das Wasser verschwindet schneller und
hinterlässt auf seinem Rückzug ganze
Schiffe
hilflos gestrandet für Wochen und Monate
den sicheren Hafen schon im Blick dachte
Schlepperkapitän Junior Cesar er würde
es noch schaffen
vergeblich wir haben versucht
freizukommen aber die Hilfe kam erst
spät und die Pegel sind sehr schnell
gesunken 30 cm am
Tag wir haben gegen die Zeit gekämpft
die Zeit war unser
Gegner nun muss Junior in seinem
bootushen dam
klautange bis das Wasser wiederkommt
hoffentlich sind wir Weihnachten zu
Hause sagt er zum
Abschied etwas weiter westlich würde das
Zuhause von Waldemar normalerweise 10 me
weiter oben schwimmen jetzt muss er im
Bett des Flusses einen Brunnen
graben das Wasser nehmen wir zum
Abwaschen Wäsche waschen Duschen
wirchütenlorin dann ist
sich auf erstenck ein aussieht ist
eigentlich ein Seitenarm des Amazonas
das Grün zeugt noch von den Wassermassen
die hier versickert und verdunstet sind
Waldemar ist 74 Jahre alt und lebt vom
Fischfang jetzt ist er gestrandet und
macht sich so seine
Gedanken je weiter der amazonaswald
abgeholzt wird desto schwieriger wird es
denn die Dürre nimmt von Mal zu Mal zu
letztes Jahr war es schon ganz schön
trocken dieses Jahr ist es noch härter
und wer weiß was nächstes Jahr ist
könnte es dann sogar noch schlimmer
werden seine Fischernetze kann Waldemar
erstmal nicht gebrauchen stattdessen
erfüllen sie einen anderen Zweck wo
sonst Boote fahren spielen Sie jetzt
Fußball und die Netze fangen
ausnahmsweise Bälle bis das Wasser
[Musik]
wiederkommt